l'accident au salon du bourget un mig 29
soviétique c'est crac à côté de la piste
il n'y a eu heureusement aucune victime
li peng et apparaît en chine le premier
ministre exhorte les militaires à la
télévision apparemment il n'a pas
convaincu en iran rafsanjani candidat
aux présidentielles est un document
exclusif dans ce journal l'équipe
d'antenne 2 dans la maison de l'imam
comédie elisabeth compte-gouttes bull
inculpés et écroués un personnage
mystérieux qui réapparaît brusquement
sur les pros sous les projecteurs de
l'actualité
dennis la finale femmes à roland garros
ce sera steffi graf
la voici contre arantxa sanchez rethel
bonsoir
un nouvel accident d'avion dans un
meeting aérien cette fois ça s'est passé
au bourget c'est un mig 29 soviétique
s'est écrasé tout à l'heure en milieu
d'après midi
heureusement il n'y a aucune victime pas
même le pilote qui est sortie vivante
c'est terrible accident
c'est vrai que ce genre d'accident fait
toujours frémir on se souvient de
l'explosion du tupolev au dessus du
bourget il ya quelques années et surtout
l'année dernière l'accident de la
patrouille de démonstration italienne en
allemagne qui a fait de nombreuses
victimes
patrick esther et philippe dumas y ont
filmé l'accident du mig 29 au bourget
regardez l'instant décisif
15h38 dans le ciel du bourget le pilote
soviétique anatoli krouglov comprendre
son mig 29 n'a plus de puissance
le midd maintenance représente le haut
de gamme de la chasse soviétique
ce biréacteur ultrapuissant avait
décollé quatre minutes auparavant pour
réaliser une impressionnante
démonstration devant des acheteurs
potentiels des figures audacieuse à 230
mètres d'altitude l'avion était cabré à
30 degrés et le pilote devait effectuer
une ressource à la verticale en retirant
toute la puissance mais l'un des
réacteurs m une flamme explosion un
atelier gros choc va alors éjecté la
verrière
puis déclencher le siège éjectable et
enfin ouvrir en partie son parachute à
20 mètres du sol
les secours arrivent en quelques
secondes le siège éjectable d'un nouveau
modèle qui peut se déclencher jusqu'au
niveau du sol a sauvé la vie au pilote à
l'hôpital bégin de vincennes les équipes
médicales signale qu à laquelle une
grotte chauffe et l'on voit sur ces
images récentes était conscient mais
souffrait d'un grave traumatisme au
stand soviétique
les mécaniciens eux étaient atterrés il
préparait le décollage d'un second mythe
mais bien sur l'ensemble des vols
étaient suspendus pour l'après midi ils
reprendront demain
l'avion s'est écrasé sur le bord de la
piste mais survolé les chalets du public
huit secondes auparavant au bourget les
conditions de démonstration sont très
stricte
l'avion ne peut évoluer en dessous de
150 m mais il est vrai que ces 150
mètres sont très très vite franchi 80
machines vont évoluer au bourget les
jours à venir
et il n'est bien sûr pas possible de
stopper ou de supprimer ces
démonstrations s'est pas passé
normalement
en revanche il est probable que les
avions soviétiques eux ne voleront plus
que pour repartir l'iran maintenant avec
un document exclusif antenne 2 alors
sachez d'abord qu'à téhéran le calme est
un petit peu revenu après trois jours de
folie en hommage à l'ayatollah khomeiny
qui est mort le week-end dernier
ce matin le président du parlement
monsieur rafsanjani a annoncé sa
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
d'août prochain
et il a dit que l'iran était prêt à
aider à la libération des otages
américains au libre mais je vous propose
maintenant de voir un document
exceptionnel notre envoyé spécial à
téhéran patricia cost a pu se rendre
dans la maison où a vécu l'imam khomeiny
au cours de ces dernières années elle a
rencontré ses proches
c'est la première fois qu'une caméra a
pu filmer ces images étonnantes voici le
reportage de patricia pénétrer dans ce
que fut l'intimité de l'imam khomeiny
c'est à dire dans son jardin dans sa
maison dans sa famille est uniquement
réservé aux femmes filles ou soeurs
d'hommes tombés dans la guerre celle ci
ont eu le rare privilège de se réunir
dans cet endroit habituellement réservé
aux tout proche
elles sont venus tenir compagnie à la
veuve aux fruits et aux petites filles
de l'imam comme celles ci sont assises à
l'iranienne sur le tapis persans sous
une petite cheminée qui est le seul
ornement de la pierre à la place des
portraits de famille aujourd'hui une
immense photo du plus illustre de leurs
parents qui a pris toute la place
elle se diront trop triste les attentes
et quelques mots seuls les pleurs ou les
slogans semble correspondre à la dignité
du deuil chiite
la dernière demeure de l'imam khomeiny
identique à celle de millions d'iraniens
est en passe de devenir un lieu de culte
qui dirige depuis ce matin par des
ruelles étroites des files
ininterrompues des plus fidèles soutiens
du régime
est passible jeu par exemple ou
volontaires qui avec les gardiens de la
révolution ont constitué le fer de lance
de la guerre contre l'irak sûrs suivront
d'autres défilés avec par exemple encore
des femmes souvent les soeurs les
épouses ou les mères des volontaires
catégorie que le régime a toujours voulu
choyés j'ajoute à propos de l'iran que
malgré les menaces persistantes sur
l'écrivain britannique salman rushdie
son livre les versets sataniques sortira
bien en france
des associations musulmanes réclamer son
interdiction
elles ont été déboutées en justice dans
leurs actions contre les éditions
christian bourgois la chine
deux faits majeurs ce jeudi la
réapparition du premier ministre li peng
et une possible intervention de l'armée
dans le quartier des universités nous
allons y revenir mais priorité aux
reportages nos envoyés spéciaux à pékin
bruno le dreff christian giroux et bruno
carette ont profité d'une relative
accalmie pour circuler dans la capitale
chinoise
voici ce qu'ils ont vu tendez bien
l'oreille la liaison n'est pas toujours
parfaite pour la première fois depuis
qu'ils ont pénétré dans belkin g2a
parcourent la ville sous leur contrôle
la visite nettoient les rues dévastées
par trois jours d'enseignement encore
la protection de blindés aujourd'hui
l'ordre nouveau mental
regardez les rares cycliste s'aventurer
dehors
pas un regard pour les soldats hier
encore ils se seraient arrêtés les
auraient interpellé critique et injuriée
aujourd'hui mais elle doit subir
l'occupation mais la vie n'a pas repris
la population observe toujours la grève
générale voici la grande artère
commerçante de belkin déserte comme la
plupart des rues de la ville impossible
depuis trois jours de se procurer de
l'essence qui était déjà rationner sol
peuvent circuler ce qu'ils ont fait
quelques réserves dans les universités
pratiquement vides la plupart des
étudiants effrayés se sont réfugiés en
province ce qui reste diffuse des
témoignages sur la dernière nuit de
tienanmen m'écoute recueilli l'un d'eux
ce qu'il a vécu accepte de nous raconter
visage caché
la loi martiale lui interdisent d'être
filmés ou interviews g nous avions un
accord avec l'armée nous devions quitter
la place aux cinq heures mais les chars
et audace et avant l'heure prévue
ils ont écrasé les femmes qui se
trouvaient autour de la statue à
l'intérieur il y avait des étudiants
malades fatigués qu'ils dormaient ils
avaient confiance c'était des
provinciaux parce que nous sommes enfuis
des bas mais nous on poursuivi nous
sommes sauvés mais j'ai vu deux filles
qui n'ont pas réussi à s'échapper
elles ont tenté d'éviter achats mais il
a écrasé la télévision chinoise présente
une autre version
régulièrement elle diffuse des images
filmées par les caméras de surveillance
de la police commentaire du journaliste
chinois un camion tombe en panne les
bandits contre-révolutionnaire c'est
désormais le terme officiel la piste le
chauffeur est l'heure de la reprise en
live est logique il faut maintenant
justifier l'intervention militaire on
voit toujours les mêmes images la
population attaquer l'armée les soldats
c'est à l'hôpital jamais la troupe tirer
comme si la sanglante répression de
tiananmen n'avait pas existé
li peng le premier ministre est donc
réapparu à la télévision c'était la
première fois qu'on le voyait depuis la
répression sanglante qui a fait je vous
le rappelle des milliers de morts avec
cette phrase terrible drilles de li peng
à l'adresse des militaires responsables
de la répression camarades vous avez
fait un dur travail
j'espère que vous continuerez alors tout
de suite nous allons retrouver comme
chaque soir au téléphone et en direct
notre envoyé spécial à pékin l'un de nos
envoyées spéciales spéciaux pardon bruno
le dress
bruno je parlais tout à l'heure d'une
possible intervention de l'armée dans
les universités est ce que vous avez des
éléments d'information nouveau weir est
en fait ce sont passés par des messages
diffusés par haut-parleurs dans le
quartier de hayden le quartier
universitaire de pékin que l'on vient
d'apprendre il y a environ une demi
heure que l'armée s'apprêterait donc à
pénétrer dans au moins trois universités
de la ville en particulier dans celles
de beda qui est l'une des plus
prestigieuses de la sinne métier surtout
l'un des hauts lieux du mouvement
étudiant depuis maintenant cinq semaines
les messages diffusés dont par
hauts-parleurs avertissent la population
que la troupe vallespir des campus et
conseillent aux habitants de pékin de
rester chez eux pour éviter tout
accident
cette intervention est pour moi un peu
une surprise dans la mesure où
l'atmosphère semblait plus calme depuis
24 heures mais il est vrai que la
plupart des étudiants que j'ai rencontré
s'attendait à une telle éventualité ils
ont d'ailleurs pour la plupart suit les
campus officiellement disait-il pour
faire savoir en province ce qui s'est
passé avec 1 en fait d'après ce que j'ai
pu voir par crainte d'une nouvelle
répression et il semblerait bien cette
nuit avec un qu'ils aient eu raison
cette intervention est tout de même je
vous le disais donc une surprise dans la
mesure où la situation semblait plus
calme depuis 24 heures
mais la réapparition de leasing le
premier mise dont vous parliez il est un
instant on l'a vu à la télévision en
costume mao souriant très sûr de lui
visiter les troupes qui ont participé à
l'écrasement des étudiantes senen la
réapparition de li peng que l'on avait
donc pas eu en public depuis le 30 mai
montré déjà que les durs dont le premier
ministre chinois est le chef de file
tiennent désormais le pouvoir bien en
main en un mot bruno c'est encore calme
ce soir à pékin cette nuit j'ai écouté
dans le dans le café où je me trouve
très très calmes là l'armée contrôle
pour l'instant me semble-t-il
définitivement les situations à pékin et
si elle intervient dans les universités
et qu'elle se tend très très forte que
le gouvernement chinois se sent lui
aussi présent merci bruno et nous
retrouvons bien sûr comme d'habitude
dans nos prochaines éditions
inquiétude à hong kong l'an clark
britannique qui se trouve aux portes de
la chine s'inquiète des troubles
le gouverneur de hong kong était reçu ce
matin en grande bretagne par le premier
ministre britannique madame margaret
thatcher c'était à londres
voici la poignée de main entre le
premier ministre et ami fan à mme
thatcher et le gouverneur de hong kong
il faut savoir que hong kong est une
possession britannique mais qu'en 1997
c'est à dire très prochainement le
territoire reviendra à la chine en vertu
d'accords récent enquête
à hong kong de nos envoyés spéciaux
martin laroche joubert dominique merlin
ironie de l'histoire
à hong kong on célèbre aujourd'hui la
journée du dragon en souvenir de ce
premier ministre chinois qui se jetaient
à l'eau et si noya volontairement pour
protester contre la corruption de son
empereur
rues désertées d'un jour férié mais où
chaque carrefour rappelle par des
banderoles des drapeaux noirs les
massacres de pékin devant l' agence de
presse officielle chinoise
des jeunes pleurs devant le couronne
mortuaire disposées ici en signe de défi
d imagerie aussi douloureuse que des
photos incliné vous devant les martyrs
subi ce jeune homme tout au long de la
journée
je suis aussi déprimé ce n'est pas parce
que je pense qu'en 1997
hong kong reviendra la chine c'est parce
que nos compatriotes ont été traitées si
brutalement et si injustement non
actuellement je pense peu à 1997
je pleure mes amis chinois mes camarades
morts d'une manière si absurde
je ne pense pas que je puisse faire
quelque chose et je suis très en colère
au plus profond de mon coeur j'ai très
très vite tous ceux qui ont perdu leurs
parents leurs enfants
je me sens des leurs
mais au delà de l'émotion et de l'envoi
c'était à hong kong par les massacres
aux chinois demain sera une journée clé
sur le plan économique la bourse de hong
kong a chuté de près de 34% depuis le
début de la loi martiale à pékin un
véritable cataclysme pour l'une des
places financières les plus importantes
du monde et il n'y a pas qu'à hong kong
où l'on s'inquiète la chine à la dérive
et c'est toute l'asie qui s'affolent les
japonais par exemple redoutent beaucoup
la persistance des soubresauts chinois
notre envoyé spécial à tokyo isabelle
bechler a pu le constater
isabelle avions spécialement affrétés
consignes de retour d'urgence retraite
en débandade l'ambassade du japon à
pékin rapatrie tant bien que mal la
plupart des 8000 japonais qui dit en
chine ce maple le siège de l'entreprise
nous a donné l'ordre de rentrer
d'urgence et j'ai laissé mon mari
derrière moi un de mes collègues a été
isolé quelque part on a perdu toute
trace et tout contact avec lui
l'angoissé des familles qui rentre de
pékin et les efforts que font les
d'entreprise pour rapatrier leur
personnel sont les troubles visible qui
inquiète les japonais à la bourse de
tokyo
en revanche influence feutré de ce début
de guerre civile chinoise contrairement
à la bourse de hong kong qui a plongé
lundi les tirs des blindés chinois n'ont
pas d'écho à kabuto de chaud pas de
grosse réaction même sur les sociétés
qui avaient pris des risques en
investissant en chine depuis les années
80 et ça c'était commerce la métallurgie
et les sociétés de produits électriques
vont exporter moins toutefois les plus
grandes entreprises prudentes n'en
souffriront pas car elles n'ont pas mis
trop deux dans le panier chinois c'est
le cas de toshiba qui fait 6 % de son
chiffre d'affaires avec la chine
inquiétude les répercussions limitées
il rompt le japon a décidé de renforcer
son aide à la chine en augmentant ses
investissements dans cet esprit chez
nous à toshiba nous avions donné une
meilleure place à la chine dans notre
stratégie mondiale jusqu'à ce que les
événements viennent tout compromettre
bien sûr si l'instabilité se poursuit
nous serons obligés de réviser tous nos
engagements à la baisse ce serait bien
regrettable
les 90 employés de toshiba résidant en
chine ont été rapatriés le ban s'en de
pékin a mis un coup d'arrêt à la
construction de deux usines qui devait
employer plusieurs milliers de chinois
beaucoup d'autres projets japonais sont
en souffrance de la même manière dans
les sociétés japonaises
on regrette que la shinra aujourd'hui
une chance de développement en france
madame compte vous de gaulle inculpés et
écroués
la mère d'harry boutboul la femme jockey
défraye de nouveau la chronique
cette fois ce n'est pas à propos de
l'assassinât de son gendre
c'est pour un autre assassinat wavre
décidément la mystérieuse elisabeth
compte-gouttes bull revient sous les
projecteurs la france entière l'avait
découverte quand elle avait accepté de
parler à la télévision
juste après le meurtre de son gendre
jacques perron en décembre 85 henry
bodiguel inculpé dès le milieu de la
matinée de complicité d'homicide
volontaire il semblerait que marie
élisabeth compte-gouttes bull est choisi
pour systèmes de défense de nier
systématiquement toutes les accusations
formulées contre elle une détermination
dont elle avait déjà fait preuve lors de
l'assassinât de son gendre
l'avocat jacques perron il y a quatre
ans maintenant pour ça je ne parle et
rit maintenant même quitte à devoir
passé 20 ans de ma vie à fleury mérogis
us à l'abri - et je ne parlerai pas le
juge beaulieu
at il voulu faire pression sur marie
élisabeth course boutboul en l'inculpant
de complicité d'homicide volontaire il
reste à savoir si les éléments dont
dispose le juge sont précisément assez
solides pour justifier sa décision
des documents retrouvés au domicile de
la victime bruno da saint-andré en tous
les cas à prouver que la mère de la
femme choquée d'harry boutboul
entretenaient des relations suivies avec
le représentant de commerce assassiné
l'audition hier de deux témoins un agent
d'assurances d'annecy et une commerçante
de paris tendre est également à le
démontrer
bien que madame compte boutboul prétend
ne pas connaître cette commerçante
kelly s'est rentré en tant que client
j'ai trouvé sympathique
c'est tout ça a été notre client sort
est exactement pareil et puis le juge
beaulieu aurait également découvert deux
importantes sorties de fonds sur les
comptes bancaires suisses de madame
cruise boutboul
l'un peu avant la mort de l'avocat
jacques perron le mari de sa fille et
l'autre peu avant la mort de bruno da
sac
quant à l'avocat maître jacques dreyfuss
il comprend mal lui la décision du juge
du havre
je considère moi pour ma peur que on
essaye de faire un amalgame entre deux
affaires dont on n'arrive pas à attirer
les solutions et que ma cliente est dans
une certaine mesure
victime d'une prise d'otage judiciaire
toujours est il qu'après avoir passé et
de nuit en garde à vue à l'hôtel de
police
c'est désormais à la prison de rouen au
quartier des femmes que marie élisabeth
compte boutboul passera les huit
suivantes le prix des automobiles en
question le ministre des finances ne
veux pas que ce prix augmentent alors il
surveille bien sûr de près son indice
des prix et c'est pourquoi ils
s'inquiètent de l'augmentation du prix
des automobiles
il a dit tout cela jacques calvet à
raymond lévy qui sont respectivement les
pdg de peugeot et de renault
alors philippe sassier c'est vrai que la
crainte du ministre et de beaucoup
d'autres c'est le retour de l'inflation
oui parce que les deux grands piliers de
la politique de pierre bérégovoy c'est
un franc fort et la poursuite de la
désinflation or depuis le début d'année
sévriens un dérapage des prix il n'ya
pas retour de l'inflation est ce que ça
signifie bien le mauvais indice du mois
d'avril 0 6% et du cre en grande partie
au pétrole et sur un an
en dehors du pétrole les prix continuent
de se ralentir on espère que tout va
rentrer dans l'ordre on attend un
meilleur indice pour le mois de mai on
parle de 0 4%
peut-être de 0 3% et puis pour la
rentrée le gouvernement prépare une
série de mesures peut-être des baisses
de tva notamment sur l'automobile
l'automobile alors ce que veut éviter à
tout prix pierre bérégovoy c'est ce que
l'on appelle des anticipations c'est à
dire des commerçants des industriels des
hommes de service qui donne un petit
coup de pouce aux étiquettes parce
qu'ils voient les privés râpé et qu'il
essaye de prendre leurs précautions et
puis il veut éviter également une
flambée de revendications des salaires
qui la ferait craquer ce cercle vertueux
dans laquelle est entré l'économie
française c'est la raison pour laquelle
pierre bérégovoy le libéral et bien a
couru le risque cet après-midi de manier
un langage pas tellement libéral devant
monsieur calvet
et monsieur lévy les deux pdg de renault
et de peugeot tous les très bonnes
raisons d'augmenter leurs prix pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont besoin d'argent pour
investir et se désendetter et pierre
bérégovoy lui ne veut absolument pas que
l'inflation revienne c'est la raison
pour laquelle il avait convoqué
aujourd'hui
merci philippe le président françois
mitterrand en visite au salon du bourget
c'était ce matin le président de la
république accompagné du ministre de la
défense s'est rendu donc au salon qui je
vous le rappelle se tient du 9 au 18
juin
le président a assisté à une
présentation en vol des principales
réalisations aéronautique français
civils et militaires monsieur mitterrand
était parti lorsque le mig-29 soviétique
s'est écrasé au milieu d'après midi
voyons maintenant d'autres informations
importantes de l'actualité de ce jeudi à
commencer par cette rencontre à paris
entre felipe gonzalez le premier
ministre espagnol et le président
mitterrand
il s'agissait de préparer le sommet
européen de madrid
isabelle de lyon séance de travail à
l'elysée thème l'europe
felipe gonzalez et françois mitterrand
veulent s'agir ensemble lors du prochain
conseil européen de madrid pour faire
avancer l'europe b12
selon le premier ministre espagnol il
faut se mettre d'accord sur une
procédure pour aller jusqu'au bout de
l'union monétaire
c'est la condition du succès
5 milliards de roubles soit un peu plus
de 50 milliards de francs c'est ce qu'a
compté chaque année pendant 10 ans
l'intervention militaire soviétique en
afghanistan
ce chiffre secret jusqu alors a été
révélée par nicolaï risk of may sur
hitchcock désigné hier comme premier
ministre par le soviet suprême a été élu
à ce poste à une écrasante majorité par
le congrès des députés du peuple
il avait présenté hier son programme
accéléré le développement de l'économie
pour mieux répondre aux besoins de la
population et réduire les dépenses
militaires
jours de soleil jour de 7 à stockholm
pour l'arrivée du pape en suède
dernière étape d'un périple nordique
messe devant plus de 15000 personnes
jean paul ii a rendu hommage aux
initiatives de la suède en faveur de la
paix et de la tolérance
hommage à un peuple accueillant envers
les immigrés et qui selon le patron
montre qu'il est possible de vivre et
travailler ensemble à l'assemblée
discussions sur la loi d'orientation sur
l'enseignement bien sûr discussions
suite car elle avait commencé dès hier
peu passion sur un thème qui pourtant a
mobilisé les énergies en un autre temps
lionel jospin remise de l'éducation
cherche apparemment le consensus avec
une idée neuve dans cette loi
d'orientation entre autres la
participation des parents à la vie au
travail du lycée c'est une idée qui est
déjà en application dans certains
collèges par exemple à grenoble serge me
serais et daniel levy s'y sont rendus
reportage du jamais vu
parents et enseignants côte à côte sur
les bancs de l'école dans ce collège
ils apprennent ensemble à aider les
élèves chacun à sa place aux enseignants
le travail pédagogique aux parents un
contrôle et un soutien vigoureux du
travail scolaire voilà la glace a été
rompu avec les professeurs ils font un
métier difficile ils sont séparés dans
wii wii fit signe je pense que quand on
les relit voisins des réunions comme
celle organisée c'est bien forcément
sympathique suivre le travail scolaire
interpréter sa finalité connaître les
notations des professeurs les niveaux
des classes
autant de notions que les parents ont
acquises au cours de ce stage et dont
ils reconnaissent aujourd'hui la valeur
n'est une certaine image de notre enfant
et bonbons ou
on en reste là et le fait justement de
ses rapports avec les professeurs bon
bah il ya certaines choses de nos
enfants qu'on ne connaît pas comment
percevez vous élève maintenant disons
que ce ne sont plus des élèves vont dans
la classe et pour eux ils viennent avec
tout un contexte familial avec leurs
problèmes on les comprend beaucoup mieux
vous appris quoi exactement comment
aider l'enfant à travailler à la maison
de quelle manière s'y prendre on nous a
donné des feuilles polycopiés en nous
expliquant telle matière comment il
fallait apprendre une leçon comment la
retenir
comment et de l'aider à travailler à la
maison parce que le gros problème
c'était souvent les enfants ne
travaillait pas la maison les plus
grands bénéficiaires de cette formation
commune sont bien évidemment les élèves
quand même si parfois cette connivence
les dérange quelque peu on fait vraiment
que les parents savent ne travaille pas
donc quand sa patrie
dans cette banlieue 60 % d'immigrés le
principal salvadori glee office de
sicilien est l'artisan de cette
initiative avant échec scolaire était
très important dans ce collège
aujourd'hui la tendance s'est
complètement inversée le congrès de
montréal sur le sida chaque année les
savants du monde entier se réunissent
maintenant pour faire le point sur cette
terrible maladie
ils sont plus d'un millier cette fois à
montréal toute la semaine on a surtout
parlé bilan que ce soit pour le nombre
de malades ou pour le résultat des
traitements mais il n'y a pas eu
malheureusement deux grandes nouveautés
pour trouver des solutions
à noter que dans ce congrès
l'influencent importante des français
c'est sentir qu'ils soient chercheurs ou
médecin daniel veygoux ce président
d'une des réunions scientifiques les
plus pointus du congrès de montréal
c'est un français jean claude chermann
un des chercheurs qui a identifié le
virus du sida en fait à montréal on a
compté 600 chercheurs france est deux
fois plus que l'an dernier à stockholm
une véritable offensive scientifiques
face à celle des américains six ans
après la découverte du virus dans le
comité d'organisation dans le comité du
programme il y avait autant de français
que l'amérique
donc vous voyez que nous méritons notre
place ici mais maintenant quand on
regarde tout ce qui se passe nombre de
chercheurs le nombre de participants on
s'aperçoit que si le nombre de français
ou non des clips a augmenté également
par rapport à ici nous allons vite être
noyées
si nous ne sommes pas aidés un peu plus
fort de son côté claude evin président
une séance plénière c'est l'offensive
politique d'une france présentée unie un
congrès où les enjeux scientifiques et
humains sont de plus en plus
considérable offensive avec un stand de
150 m² au coeur même du palais des
congrès où les industriels français les
associations les pouvoirs publics ont pu
démontrer les efforts de la france dans
la lutte contre le sida
il faut que les chercheurs se battent
pour pouvoir obtenir un traitement
pouvoir trouver mais tant que les
chercheurs n'ont pas trouvé
c'est une réponse globale qu'il nous
faut avoir c'est une réponse avec les
associations de malades c'est une
réponse avec les associations qui font
du soin c'est une réponse avec notre
système de santé
c'est une réponse qui mobilise tout le
monde et ça je crois que c'est ce qui
caractérise la lutte que la france mène
sur la scène internationale reste que la
france n'a pas réussi à 100% et de loin
son offensive face à la suprématie
américaine
ainsi à montréal dans cette ville
symbole qui se bat pour imposer le
bilinguisme la quasi totalité des
interventions orales et écrites se sont
faites en anglais
certes le français n'aurait rien changé
au débat scientifique mais serait était
l'expression d'une autre culture
tennis force est restée à la loi ou
plutôt victoire est revenue à la force
il s'agissait des demi finales dames
aujourd'hui est en tout cas dans la
première demi finale du simple dames
effectivement la victoire est revenue à
la force puisque steffi graf
comme prévu jean ma mère est venue à
bout de la jeune et prometteuse monica
seles effectivement un terreau peu
distrait je dirais harvey parce que
d'abord l'on assisté qu'à une seule
belle demi-finale et que celle label à
laquelle on assiste et c'est à dire
entre monica seles et steffi graf et
bien on a eu l'impression que c'était la
finale de roland-garros avant l'heure il
est vrai que monica seles c'est la plus
jeune joueuse de ce tournoi est la
révélation 1989
et puis steffi graf et bien c'est la
tenante du titre mais elle a cet
après-midi tremblé sur son piédestal les
photographes d'ailleurs ne s'y était pas
trompé et il n'avait d'yeux que pour
elle mme monica seles la nouvelle
vedette du tennis
quant à la reine steffi elle pestait
contre elle même au point de se demander
où était passé son tennis à un moment de
l'après midi il est vrai qu'après avoir
remporté le premier set telegraph a
connu une période trouble dans le
deuxième
débordé par les accélérations de monica
seles
elle a même par moment oui une petite
leçon de tennis
mais le principe des grandes championnes
et de se ressaisir au bon moment ce qu a
fort bien fait steffi graf dans le
troisième set après 1h30 de jeu monica
seles a bien du mal à soutenir le rythme
alors très élevé elle craque au milieu
du troisième mais c'est laisse
aujourd'hui a fait trembler la reine est
prouvé que demain elle peut très bien la
renverser alors jean ont déçu un peu par
la deuxième demi finale
oui parce qu'il n'y a pas vraiment eu de
match je dirais entre arantxa sanchez
l'espagnol et mary joe fernandez mary
joe fernandez dont on attendait mieux
elle avait éliminé sabatini en huitièmes
de finale
mais aujourd'hui on peut dire que mary
joe fernandez n'a été que l'ombre d'elle
même
alors peut-être at-elle été impressionné
impressionné par la masse physique
particulièrement musclé d'arantxa
sanchez une vraie joueuse de terre
battue cet espagnol avec un grand jeu de
jambes et une forme qui lui permet de se
sortir de presse
toutes les situations la preuve
fernandez la malheureuse n'en revient
pas alors ça a donné un match expéditif
et sans problème pour en rendre sa
sanchez tête de série numéro sept mais
qui crée tout de même reconnu si on veut
une certaine surprise par son accession
à cette finale de roland garros 1989
mais ne devrait pas y avoir de finale on
met quand même super favori steffi graf
et b je voudrais question les le petit
winogradsky j'ai envie des biens qui ont
repris leur nez il y aura un français en
finale de roland garros qu'elles veulent
également eric winogradsky qui s'est
qualifié avec le l'iranien mansour
bahrami sont qualifiés pour la finale en
trois sets zéro ils seront opposés à la
paire américaine crabe mcenroe qui sera
pas john
enfin le frère bien sûr patrick mcenroe
merci jean dans le tour d'italie
cycliste c'était la 19e étape fignon un
petit peu rassuré ses supporters vous
savez que hier dans l'étape contre la
montre il avait perdu du terrain et bien
non cette fois il a tenu le coup fini
ont marre un maillot rose toujours donc
c'est le danois skibby vous allez le
voir sur ces images qui gagne l'étape au
sprint devant trois autres compagnons
d'échappée il n'y a donc pas de
changement au classement général et à
quelques jours de l'arrivée
vous êtes un petit peu rassurés et touré
bien remporter ce tour d'italie
le théâtre pour terminer avec une pièce
au titre appétissant cela s'appelle
lapin chasseur c'est à chaillot c'est la
dernière création de jérôme deschamps
l'idée c'est un restaurant vue des deux
côtés côté salé côté cuisine
alors on voit deux fois le même
spectacle de deux points de vue
différents
hervé brusini et bernard puis ce saut
par l'odeur alléché sont entrés dans ce
théâtre voici le chef le restaurant
lapin chasseur
vous l'aurez remarqué nous sommes ici
côté sale et côté salsa balance ça
balance
le gade sauce du restaurant et celui ci
c'est un mitron d'un genre un peu
particulier
m
cela c'était pour le côté cuisine car à
chaque bout de ce spectacle il y a deux
côtés avec deux groupes de spectateurs
qui suivent la même représentation sous
deux angles différents
alors à l'entracte forcément ils
changent de place pour voir ce qu'ils
n'ont pas encore vu enfin le metteur en
scène nous a aidés à mieux comprendre
cette double mécanique et je comprends
je crois qu'on prend et par exemple
demain vous ça continue le spectacle
continue à bord on va le mais on est
arrivé on vous remercie pour toutes vos
explications
voilà il y avait un tiers fait
aujourd'hui alors tout de suite je vous
donne les résultats 4 5 1
je vous laisse lire les rapports vous le
faites mieux que moi et puis dans non
plus tôt le kart et bien sûr ses 4,5 aph
et le 3 je vous laisse lire encore les
rapports
il y à une météo s'est tout de suite ce
sera avec laurent cabrol qui promet une
amélioration normalement il devrait pas
pleuvoir à roland garros la dernière
édition
henri sannier vers 23h30 et puis demain
6h30 télématin comme chaque jour télé
matin qui demain comme chaque vendredi
poursuit son tour d'europe ranger est
belle roger zabel
bonsoir j'ai tranché isabelle doha pour
inviter cette fois une famille espagnole
de barcelone excellente soirée à demain
20 heures